[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture nous sommes ravis de
vous retrouver avec nathalie wolf ça va
très bien le centriste doit on va parler
de moeurs nacht hockey ah oui on va
parler pas là va parler polar avec notre
invité cardinaux bonjour bonjour alors
on va parler de votre dernier roman pour
quelques millions paru aux éditions la
joie dit
mais pour vous présenter c'est vrai que
vous avez vous êtes auteur d'une
trilogie qui est du très beau succès des
qui s'appelait les nuits nantaises
y'avait l'arménien il ya eu le de
sicilien et le nantais 1re manqué alors
le déroulement d'ailleurs été primée
ça vous a fait acquérir un public assez
fidèle non je pense alors oui c'est vrai
que la trilogie a bien marché en fait
c'est un roman le premier est paru en
2017 il était en auto édition et a il
avait obtenu un prix de blogueurs et du
coup le roman était connu et quand j'ai
connu jean charles je vais renvoyer deux
siciliens aux manuscrits et quand il a
dû d'arméniens il m'a dit oui je leur ai
dit et finalement c'est lui qui a suivi
toute la tribu
alors on va parler aussi un petit peu
vous mais c'est vrai que vous vivez
entre la france et la thaïlande enfin
pas exactement entre la france avait t
il une saison au trianon lomé
la france et de thaïlande est un grand
voyageur on va parler aussi de cuba que
visiblement vous connaissez très bien
mais peut-être avant d'entrer plus avant
dans le roman lui-même un mot sur sur le
polar pourquoi vous avez choisi le polar
pour exprimer est ce que ça vous permet
d'avoir des typologies personnage qui
vous intéressent est-ce que les
contraintes du polar sont importantes
pour vous aussi alors en fait j'ai
commencé à écrire de l'arménien j'étais
au canada on a vécu six ans au canada et
j'avais passé deux ans création
littéraire o myler absolument pas ce que
je voulais merci à laval 1 c'est ça vous
les professionnaliser mon écriture est
le polar me semblait intéressant parce
que le polar permet de faire des photos
de notre société fait on reconnaît une
société à travers sa délinquance et à
travers ces mariages mans cette année
voire plus aujourd'hui on voit là et
donc l'idée de la trilogie justement
c'était de faire trois photos comme ça
en instantané sur trois intrigues
indépendante les années 80 les années 90
et des années 2000 qui nous permettent
de voir évoluer notre société à travers
des personnages mais aussi à travers à
travers des intrigues qui chacune
d'entre elle correspond à la violence au
degré de violence et aussi à l'évolution
des trafics à l'évolution de la
délinquance et je pense que ça le polar
le permet et puis ça nous donne aussi
des personnages forts c'est à dire que à
chaque fois qu'on va on va chercher pas
des gens qui ont commis des meurtres on
va chercher aussi la part d'ombré de
l'humain et c'est ce qui m'intéresse
dans le poêle et puis vos et puis ça
permet de toujours qui permet de
raconter des histoires quand même c'est
ça c'est à dire que quand on quand on
veut emballer le lecteur il est
convenable d'intentions de vote roman
c'est vrai qu'on a voyagé les patchs
turner comme on dit en face d'hier on a
envie d'aller plus loin cette fois on ne
peut pas le poser quoi il essaie ça
c'est à dire de faire des roms en eau le
lecteur de la chp à l'île longue qu'ils
soient surpris à la fin qui sont
attachés aux personnages et en même
temps quand il referme le livre il a eu
quelque chose de plus alors dans la
trilogie c'était cette fameuse photo des
années 80 des années quatre mots liste
des années 2000 dans celui ci on est
plus sur les vaisseaux journal financier
et financier l'état de notre monde
actuellement et puis cette espèce de
comparaison entre le monde occidental
notre monde et puis le nom de
communistes et les uns et par cuba
et puis la façon dont les gens vivent et
puis aussi cette distanciation qui peut
y avoir entre les instances dirigeantes
d'un pays oui la façon dont le peuple
vit en dessous avec ses différences et
finalement ces rapprochements aussi
on va essayer de résumer le livre c'est
parce que comme tu l'as dit patrice il
ya beaucoup de rebondissements doit
aussi plusieurs personnages principaux
qui sont et c'est ce que j'ai apprécié
dans votre livre complexe voilà c'est
pas binaire est donc finalement c'est
pas évident mais on va quand même tenté
le pitch est peut-être en partant de vos
deux personnages principaux qui au fond
sont tous les deux des enfants mal aimés
et alors on va rester à paris est
d'abord il y à conrad c'est le fils
d'une femme extrêmement riche qui a qui
a écrit et dirigé une ong d'ailleurs
cette femme est morte
voilà dans la wii presque devant ses
yeux l'huile hollande billy était dans
la maison et n'a pas vu sa mère être
tuée alors est ce que c'est un
assassinat est ce que c'est un suicide
ça fait partie des des intrigues de l'
ouvrage je ne dirai rien mais leurs
poteaux 10 ans font mal aimé c'est vrai
qu'il a des relations très tendues avec
son père le père est soudainement devenu
riche puisqu'il hérite de sa femme
évidemment les soupçons se portent sur
lui et puis il ya une enquête mais il
est blanchi par par cette enquête mais
bon voilà les soupçons restent reste là
alors peut-être avant qu on s'envole
vers cuba dans une minute parlez nous un
peu de ce calme a le droit de cora
devait effectivement c'est un enfant mal
aimé qui vit avec une culpabilité il vit
à qu'une avec une culpabilité parce que
sa mère s'est suicidée sur cette péniche
aménagée sous la tour eiffel et il était
là ce jour là et il ne se souvient de
rien c'est forcément un choc et il vit
avec ça et il vient que ce doute est il
vit avec cette impression que il aurait
peut-être pu faire quelque chose c'est
un lourd passé et donc ça c'est celui de
conrad il a effectivement une relation
conflictuelle avec son père lorsque son
père pourrait être un des protagonistes
et en plus il voit son père comme celui
qui a abusé de la fortune de son lot 2 à
2 alors il a bu un peu fou enfin pas
choisi le camp de son père on peut pas
dire ça parce qu'ils ont des rapports
très très tôt il ma femme est bon il ne
croit pas forcément cette culpabilité
informant faut le dire mais c'est
probable que le traumatisme de la mort
de sa mère l'a conduit un peu vers la
marginalisation il pourrait bosser il a
enfin
on voit bien qu'ils recherchent un peu
la marginalité 1 alors en fait c'est un
c'est un enfant à la marge c'est à dire
c'est un enfant qui est sur ce fil du
rasoir où il peut basculer d'un côté ou
de l'autre c'est aussi ce qui fait
l'intérêt des ans non c'est d'avoir des
personnages comme ça dont on ne sait pas
de quel côté ils vont tomber et leur
passé celles comme sinon dans la vie
mais saute comme souvent dans la vie
quand il ya eu des drames d'existence et
lui c'est son cas et effectivement ils
voudraient travailler voudrais réussir
et en même temps il subit des mauvaises
influences et il pourrait facilement
basculer dans quelque chose de plus
difficile puisqu'il sera évidemment dans
le
c'est ça qui trop tard parce que il faut
quand même donner quelques éléments bien
sûr et puis après vous êtes au lieu de
s'arrêter ouais c'est ça qui nous emmène
à cuba alors oui
oui moi aussi
alors d'opter à conrad premiers pas de
personnage principal dhiya dahlia
deuxième personnes se prévalant l'atv à
cuba
juste d'alias et une référence à james
ellroy sort un peu aussi mais c'est
aussi un prénom qu'on trouve aqpa mais
oui bien sûr sur de la mémoire que
conrad et le referee l'écrivain on voit
la nationa mais face à ces qui
comprennent maladroit anecdotique c'est
vrai elle est sympa aussi de deux trains
bondés à des auteurs de référence à des
écrivains de référence aux murs et donc
cette dalle y avait dans un milieu
pauvre
cuba cuba qui est évidemment déchirée
par la corruption la pauvreté on
reparlera d'ailleurs des
disques de squeezer s'est dite des
différences entre les classes
dirigeantes et et les autres et surtout
elle est alors elle aussi pas de mer non
un mal fait un point commun voilà ce qui
fait un point comment aux 2es et des
rapports alors encore plus compliqué
avec le père puisque le père abuse
d'elle et ça et il est prêt il est prêt
à la prostituée d'ailleurs aussi si
certains moments du niveau c'est un
assortiment bonne et je suis jamais
voilà c'est le père c'est le propre
prototype de l'apparatchik déchu
c'est à dire celui qui occupait des
postes importants dans l'administration
cubaine militaires et qui a déchu et qui
est qui
livide de subsides et du coup qui est
retombé dans ce que font beaucoup de
cubains aussi vive de subsides mais qui
est absolument abominable et qui abuse
de sa fille et et elle elle se bat pour
elle ce geste parce qu'elle a un frère
elle se bat un petit frère et donc son
combat c'est de sauver son frère parce
que voilà
c'est la pauvreté aux siens qui conduit
à servas et survivre le survivre dans un
pays où se nourrir être un combat
quotidien et puis elle se bat pour
protéger son frère de celle de son père
de son père et lui alors d'alias et un
personnage féminin et c'est vrai que
dans ceux dans ce livre ce qui nous a
beaucoup marqués patrice et moi même
c'est cette place que vous accordez aux
femmes d'ailleurs le livre s'ouvre sur
cette scène de meurtre absolument
terrible et ça nous donne quand même
d'ores et déjà un indice du tableau
général
de votre roman policier c'est la
violence subie par les femmes subies par
les femmes à cuba ou à paris les femmes
elles sont voilà souvent battue violée
prostituée de force donc des femmes
victimes et en même temps on a des
personnages féminins qui sont
extrêmement forts qui vont se défendre
d'ailleurs l'enquète c'est pas si
fréquent est mené par une par une femme
c'est
mais manu l'énergie
ceate croit josée mystérieuse chez à
l'énigmatique
sur des femmes fortes aux invités mais
c'est vrai que le premier sentiment est
on se refuse de parler qu'on a eu en
lisant le livre on est pas on se dit
quand même toutes ces femmes là son être
wade elles sont vingt alors il faut il
faut pénétrer un peu dans le livre pour
comprendre que oui derrière derrière
cette façade même même cette banuls a
comme ça comme ça un moment pour ce
qu'elle accepte tout de deux sauts de
son amant on va comprendre que ce sont
des femmes très forte ou réalité en fait
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
un tableau du monde et quand on veut
montrer le monde il faut montrer le
monde tel qu'il est et tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui est bien dans beaucoup de
pays les femmes subissent manuela ilie
d'origine ukrainienne c'est une femme
qui a été enlevé c'est une femme qui
était constitué il faut pas masquer les
choses telles qu'elles sont et donc je
montre ça parce que ce sont des vraies
références de ce qui se passe on est en
même temps sa faculté à elles deux la
même que dès que des liens à surmonter
tout ça en font les véritables héroïnes
du lit c'est à dire que malgré ces
violences et bien finalement ce sont
elles qui triomphe ce sont elles qui se
battent et quand on referme le livre
comme je disais tout à l'heure on
referme le livre on a eu quelque chose
de plus et on a eu effectivement ce
monde féminin qui nous qu'ils capable de
subir une élection locale
assez rare que ses amis un peu
abstrait mais l'effet est construit
d'une façon un peu atypique c'est à dire
que ce sont des facettes de personnages
comme ça non à voir des scènes comme ça
entre paris et cuba et petit à petit
chaque scène construite intrigue pour
nous emmener vers le dénuement et petit
à petit on me rentre de plus
profondément dans la psyché de chacun
des personnages et on se rend compte de
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière la façade et
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière qu'ils ont
bien il face à veiller une réalité qu'il
réalité intérieure s'est pas dont
valérie et les femmes dans ce roman se
révèlent être les finalement les vrais 0
les vraies héroïnes absolument oui parce
que et c'est vrai que si on regarde les
mecs dans l'ensemble pour pas il faut
pas rêver ils sont
peu de dons il ronfle il
bat gnole ça c'est facile c'est vrai sur
le notamment au père de conrad de faire
d'autres sont pas sales enquêteurs le
responsable de manu ilie paris n'ait pas
donné le nom oui mais mais quelque part
dans la gestion qu'il doit avoir de
hiérarchie qu'avec elle il se rend
compte qu'il est face à quelqu'un dont
il ne peut pas donner des ordres il faut
qu'il obtienne son adhésion et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est à dire que
même s'il ya une hiérarchie entre eux et
bien par la personnalité de manu et bien
il est obligé d'agir avec elle et de la
laisser faire parce qu'il se rend compte
que ce quelqu'un qui l'a d'abord à une
acuité intellectuelle qui a une force et
un dynamisme et qu'on ne peut pas faire
obéir simplement en donnant désormais
parce que il faut qu'il obtienne son
adhésion d'ailleurs c'est qu'il l'a
repéré et qu'il arthur est en dehors de
cela vous voilà dans un guide et enfin
voilà c'est ça où elle
le voyait très bien qu'ils étaient là
qu'est ce que les gens explique aurélie
études région dans un dîner mondain avec
un peu d'alcool est repéré finalement
quels sont les typologies de chacun d un
des individus il s'est rendu compte
qu'elle avait décelé qu'elle avait bien
bien mis en place chacun des convives et
là il s'est dit je suis face à quelqu'un
qui a une acuité intellectuelle qui va
pouvoir me servir dans les enquêtes
réalisées par ses personnages tout à
fait imaginaire où vous êtes alors verra
d'aidé alors comme souvent on construit
des personnages à travers bien sûr de
l'imagination plusieurs années à travers
aussi des recherches des ddd type
biologique personnages qu'on trouve dans
des faits divers ou des choses comme ça
beaucoup de lecture et puis petit à
petit de personnages se façonne jusqu'à
aller au plus loin dans un compte dans
sa complexité
et puis tout d'un coup il prend son
autonomie et à ce moment là où on le
fait on le fait vivre de façon à ce
qu'ils s'intègrent au mans mais c'est
plusieurs étapes en fait ce qui fait que
personne ne peut dire ça personnage il
est je le connais et en même temps à
chaque fois ils représentent quelque
chose qui peut nous illustrer crise
c'est à dire bah ce personnage
arrivistes qui a réussi grâce à un
mariage
oui ça va nous voilà qui est intéressé
par l'apparence que par leur être et ce
en vieillissant et que et puissant
vieillissant est faible plus il a besoin
justement de rajouter des couches d'ego
et de de possession pour pour payet bon
bah c'est quelque chose que l'on peut on
peut tous croisé un jour dans
l'existence et donc il représente sa
raison sa manucure présente cette femme
qui a été abusée
et puis enlevée avec ce qu'elle a subis
et qui en même temps est capable de le
surmonter mais quelqu'un dont
vous êtes revenir dans mon sur cuba
parce que d'accord on avait elle avait
effleuré vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est vrai vous décrivez très bien cette
société je sais pas c'est alors ça on
est il ya quelques années je ne sais pas
si c'est toujours le cas mais vous je
crois que vous connaissez très bien cuba
où il ya en effet une grande différence
une pauvreté très très forte du peuple
et puis il ya des des dirigeants au fond
qui s'en mettre plein les poches
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui fait quand
on dit ça on se dit comme qu'est ce qui
fait que ce régime tient depuis si
longtemps
qu'est ce qui fait que ce régime tient
depuis si longtemps ça je vais avoir un
peu de mal à vous dire ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est un régime qui s'est
toujours affilié à d'autres régimes
communistes qui les ont maintenu la tête
hors de l'eau moi je suis allé à cuba la
première fois c'était dans les années 90
après la pérestroïka les virus les aux
essais et ils se sont retrouvés dans une
situation très difficile financièrement
c'est ce qui a fait mon premier voyage
qu'un ami on s'était dit tiens on va
créer un petit à petit leur essor
touristique pour leur envoyer des fax à
l'époque et puis ils ont reçu comme si
on était le club med ou ou
et parce que ce sont les apparatchiks
qui font pas de distinction il n'avait
pas l'habitude de connaître ça et ils
nous ont emmenés dans des endroits où
personne n'était allé depuis
2007 perdue où vous aviez encore les
vieilles maisons des mafieux peu de
l'époque d'avant la révolution qui est
en train de se délabrer avec l'idée
qu'on allait faire des trucs touristique
de 200 de 200 chambres alors que nous on
voulait juste faire un petit ressorte
mais ça nous a permis vraiment il il
avait réquisitionné des bateaux des deux
bateaux de pêche parce que les bateaux
n'ont pas le droit de s'éloigner des
coudes parce qu'ils ont peur que les
gens sont égaux s'en aille il avait
réquisitionné des militaires enfin voilà
donc ça nous a permis ce voyage de dalé
de de passer beaucoup de barrières dans
une époque en plus ou de cuba était
encore pas très tous c'était ma promo
même la première confrontation au pays
et puis j'ai passé des heures à discuter
avec des apparatchiks c'est à dire que
vous arrivez dans des bureaux qui date
des années 50 nous avez la photo du 2 2
4 euros vous avez la photo de votre
interlocuteur qui est avec castro qui
est encore en tenue militaire et là vous
allez passer
quatre heures 5 heures à parler pour ne
rien dire juste pour eux occuper le
temps et faire de la parole de la même
façon que vous avez ses discours fleuve
de castro sont ces révisions une seule
chaîne et les enfants sont élevés
biberonné à cela ses discours fleuves
donc ça c'est intéressant quand même de
le décrire ça et puis cette dichotomie
c'était caricature
heurter les apparatchiks ils vivent
reclus dans des dents des les anciennes
maisons de ceux qu'ils ont délogé des
mafieux où les américains qui vivent
reclus dans le luxe et puis la pauvreté
du peuple qui est lié à la fois au
système et à l'embargo donc là après oui
la part de l autre c bon chacun y mettra
évidemment en fonction de ce qu'ils de
ce qu'ils croient le plus hot la réalité
c'est qu'il ya un vrai écart entre ce
que vit le peuple et puis ce que vivent
ces apparatchiks qui disent vivre
travailler pour le peuple et ça je pense
que c'était une façon de décrire
gouvernement du peuple et ils vivent
dans le luxe dont les castro était quand
même des gens très très très très riche
et là je pense que le symbole là il est
décrit dans le livre là encore ça fait
partie de ce que on a en plus en plus je
crois quand on ferme le livre mais
toujours à travers un personnage parce
que dalia elle elle symbolise cette
jeunesse qui se bat au jour le jour dans
ce pays qui voit bien les apparatchiks
mais c'est pour elle c'est pas le sait
pas le souci son souci nc20 il se
faisait de se défendre et nourrir son
frère ça rejoint d'ailleurs on arrive à
un autre thème de votre livre qui qui
qui est là derrière la double intrigue
dont on a dont on a déjà parlé c'est qui
est un scandale financier qui ressemble
à celui des panamas peppers et vous le
rappeler en exergue de votre livre les
les produits de ces scandales financiers
se chiffrent en centaines de milliards
de dollars alors comment est ce que on
va se prendre quand on écrit donc comme
vous pour pour rendre accessibles au
fonds cic grand scandale financier qui
serait même très technique il faut bien
le dire voilà ce qu'on a les gens me
disent polar faut se dire c'est que
quand on quand on commence à écrire là
dessus c'est de se dire voilà je suis
pas journaliste et je fais pas un livre
est par contre je dois être aussi pointu
qu'un journaliste parce que tout ce que
je vais dire doit être vrai donc tout ce
que je dis dans le livre est vrai mais
un moment
voilà encore l'entendre le lecteur ferme
le livre il a été renseigné sur ce sujet
mais de façon presque subliminale sans
jamais qu'il veuille se dire faisant
migrer non on est dans l'intrigué on est
dans les personnages emmené avec eux on
essaye de faire du pepsi turner et on
fait en sorte que le lecteur soit
surpris à la fin mai qu'il ait été ému
par moments
choquée presque pas par d'autres parce
que c'est ça le polar eu d'effet pour
générer des émotions et une surprise et
pour autant la peinture du mot ou montre
qu' aujourd'hui las des scandales
financiers
dans en occident qui détourne parfois
pour des velléités politique d'accession
au pouvoir des milliards et que
évidemment c'est milliards serait quand
même mieux utilisé six étaient destinés
au prince et ac dc des médias ne
l'avouent d'evry en exergue du livre
alors celui que je prends en exemple en
france je veux pas le citer parce que là
encore ce n'est pas du journalisme mais
il est vrai elle y fait référence des
détails sont là tous les états y sont
vraies y compris les détournement
d'armes et tout ça tout ça ce sont des
choses vraies mais 56 tu parles le
l'essentiel du livre non parce que
message subliminal quoi désolation à
cette intéressante justement interrogé
l'écrivain sur comment on fait alors
c'est vrai que c'est toujours les mêmes
ressorts c'est l'avidité c'est le le
goût de l'argent vins qui sont derrière
gaulle alors
certaines essences que vous dites parce
que c'est un roman sur lequel vous avez
beaucoup travaillé
il avait un autre titre n'est pas je
crois ce thème à l'école c'est ça oui
oui je voulais l'appeler malecon parce
que c'est ce remblai le long du bas-rhin
à cuba oui où se retrouve le soir tous
les cubains et on a cette espèce de
faune
passionnante que je décris d'ailleurs
dans le livre avec avec une strate selon
qu'on s'enfonce plus ou moins loin dans
le temps le malecon et donc c'est
vraiment le symbole et puis il ya un
moment coran à conrad quand il est assez
moment de choix dans le livre il va
aller sur ce le sera aux lèvres et il ya
ce basculement du personnage selon le
choix qui va faire à ce moment là sa vie
pourrait devenir complètement différente
donc comme c'est un moment charnière et
que c'est un endroit symbolique de cuba
j'avais envie de l'appeler comme ça
jean-charles lundi à très juste titre
que et bien sûr la joie dit le terrain
c'était pas un nom très parlant de
zurich mais c'est le bon gars assez dire
vous l'avez écrit réécrivent les bons
seulement qu'est ce qui vous convenait
pas dans les dépôts vie d'homme version
alors en fait j'ai commencé à l'écrire
entre l'arménien et l'esa et le sicilien
après un voyage à cuba et puis je les
retravailler c'est presque un livre
d'apprentissage d'écriture parce que je
voulais affiner le style je voulais
rendre créer des images a filé des
personnages donc comme toujours mes
livres j'ai écrit que les astres poser
six mois et puis après julien grenet
sont fait comme ça
cela ferait alors faites
le mur y intérieurement on regarde ta
part ce livre là une particularité d'un
point de vue écriture c'est que en 2016
je lai entièrement réécrit c'est à dire
qu'après avoir travaillé plusieurs
années sur ce livre est bien un moment
j'ai dit d'accord maintenant je sais ce
que je veux faire donc je mets de côté
ce manuscrit je l'entends je l'antre
dans le scandale du panama peppers
est-ce que ça correspondait exactement
l'image que je voulais donner de l'état
actuel de notre monde et de cet aréna
sacs à main des dirigeants aussi bien
dans le monde occidental que dans le
monde que communiste et cette différence
qu'il ya avec ce que vit le peuple au
jour le jour ça s'y prêtait et là je me
suis dit je vais je vais je je vais de
réécrire un peu où ça et comme
la sculpteure ou quelqu'un comme ça
maintenant je suis je vois c'est une
ruelle et j'ai lavé bon moment si l'on
relit je relis ce tout et puis j'y
retourne parce que je sais ce que je
veux faire c'est d'être un bon moment 50
ans dit ça y est je sais ça fait un
moment c'est un moment à la fois
difficile parce que vous avez des vous
acceptez de dire je laisse des mois et
des saisons et
je redémarre mais mais il ya quelque
chose au fond de soi qu'il dit c'est ça
qu'il faut faire pour celui là c'est ça
qui vous faire donc c'est comme c'est
comme ça que pour quelques millions et
est né après le plusieurs de plusieurs
années de travail
parcours varié intéressant vous êtes né
à nantes alors c'était l'objet de la de
la trilogie qu'on a vu que vous avez
aussi travaillé très jeune dans le
milieu de la nuit c'est ça oui en fait
moi je suis né à nantes j'ai vécu
jusqu'à l'âge de 40 ans mais à 18 ans je
faisais partie de cette génération ou
maman tu es tout seul avec elle celle
d'office le côté j'étais amené au bac là
donc j'ai fait mon boulot maintenant
c'est à toi donc
c'était très bien parce que je faisais
partie de ces ganac avait aussi envie de
vivre de faire ses propres expériences
aventure j'ai commencé à animer les
soirées dans une discothèque nantaise et
je m'occupais de du relationnel et puis
un petit peu de tout j'ai fait ça
plusieurs années ce qui m'a permis
effectivement de connaître le milieu des
nuits nantaises et aussi de confronter
la fin de ce qu'on appelle le milieu
nantais donc j'ai connu ces jeux c'est
séjour large jamais fait partie de leur
milieu mais j'animais les soirées et
d'un point de vue humain tout simplement
et puis la nuit formes et formats triste
à dire que bercy ouais elle elle permet
aussi de déceler les individus puis de
les voir évoluer de 8h et puisqu'on les
retrouve à 4 heures du matin ce sont pas
les mêmes donc il ya beaucoup de choses
très intéressantes d'avoir fait un peu
déçu mais pour le financier que vous
allez en indonésie
le départ pour québec dont vous parliez
il faut pas faire ça toute sa vie voilà
c'est ce sont des métiers qui sont
conviés il sait qu'ils sont dangereux et
après il ya l'âge de 40 ans avec ma
femme et mes deux garçons on est parti
au québec au québec est ce que est ce
que c'est la vie on a vécu six ans voilà
et vous avez pris des cours je suis
retourné on y verrait ce que s comme
c'est le québec qui ont un peu et le
pays américains enfin est-ce que vous
êtes plus influencé par les auteurs de
polars américains que par l'éditeur
français alors je lis beaucoup je lis
énormément mais pas que du polar
j'ai quelques auteurs américains quand
même qu'ils waikiki qui sont des
références mais mais finalement je
j'écris les collard mai mais je les
aborde aussi un peu comme de la
littérature blanche dans le sens où je
vais me creuser la psychologie des
personnages joués dans l'humain c'est à
dire que moi ce qui m'a intéressé c'est
pas tellement la technique de l'intrigué
qu'est ce qu'il va faire le resort
adn et tout ça qui va permettre de
déterminer la preuve dans tous ses
polars là je les lis mais c'est moins
c'est moins mon
ce vers quoi je le donne à l'extérieur
voilà que de la littérature finalement
et pas seulement du polar mais s'il
devant cité ou i treva niant sont des
auteurs comme ça qu'il ya une écriture
sublime et qui à chaque livre propose
quelque chose de différent que ça c'est
ce que j'ai aussi envie de faire de
l'écriture pour quelques millions en
bons policiers mais pas que
une petite question
dans votre lit mais c'est un pin où il
serait dans les services se fait
pas si vous dites non c'est
bien remporter des points ouais
président non mais c'est vrai si c'était
vrai si c'était vrai il n'aurait jamais
laissé
j'ai pour passionnant d'un collègue à
polytechnique qui travaille sur les
écrivains et romanciers
qu'utilisent les services secrets
justement
ça existe comment les services secrets
voilà alors que ça que j'en aurai
mentionnant au moment de la guerre
froide lorsque les les gros auteur de 2
des services secrets c'est vraiment
l'époque de la guerre froide la règle
avant on avait vraiment des sujets c'est
moins vrai
ça va peut-être venir avec elle avec la
chine avec la chine et qui avec ses
nouveaux moyens de télé payante
mais d'entendre aujourd'hui dans la
presse de deux diplomates américains
d'autre les parties du monde qui
reviennent avec des maux de tête et
voyait pas trop ce qui se passe et
notamment à la
vallée les américains m'ont dit qu'il
ferait la lumière là dessus
il ya un moment moi je m'étais dit que
c'était presque psychosomatiques quoi
c'est halak a pointé un moment où il y
en a un qui commence et glee et puis
finalement sans doute non c'est très
intéressant parce que le bâtiment où
sont les américains qui ont toujours là
c'est l'endroit où castro faisait ses
discours c'est à dire que gastro quand
il faisait ses discours plus au public
il mettait ce bâtiment derrière lui il y
avait finalement tout le peuple conviés
à venir écouter son discours et pendant
quatre heures il pouvait parler et il
l'a injurié les américains qui était
juste dans le vallon des rivières de ça
donne des scènes colle
à catherine au bourguet communion robots
policiers mais pas que opposition mais
la smag merci infiniment merci
merci
[Musique]